part of the reason salma took so long to
make is because up until recently the
idea of black protagonists in the center
of their own narrative in terms of films
of this nature historical films how
they've mostly been told through the
eyes of white characters it isn't until
films like the butler and 12 years a
slave came along and did very well
critically and at the box office that
you know we're seeing a little bit of a
sea change i know for a fact that summer
I was a beneficiary of those two films
doing what they did I think the truth of
the matter is that we all want to see
ourselves in movies and if the people
who have green light power or a certain
section of society that's what you see
on the screen is a reflection of the
people who have the power to say yes and
so I just think we just need to
diversify that because it seems quite
unbelievable but this story martin
luther king's story hasn't been told
more prominently in hollywood before I
mean what luck for you I know you know
there's a part of me that's very annoyed
at the fact that it's taken so long
there's a part of me that's very
relieved because it probably wouldn't
have been me if it had happened sooner
so uh so yeah it is it is kind of crazy
but I'm so happy that it's happened now
and i truly feel like you know we have
given the world a film that doesn't just
accentuate his reputation as an icon but
shows you the man behind the historical
figure and like i say we go to the
movies to see ourselves if we can see a
little piece of ourselves in dr. King I
think that can only be a good thing a
lots of awards season buzz around this
and how important is that to you how
exciting is it it's definitely exciting
important well you know it does bring
attention to the film it does make
people want to see the film so from that
point of view it's significant and
fantastic also as an actor it's a very
subjective profession you you tend to
not really know that you're a good actor
unless people tell you